[Musique]
en 2000 après jésus-christ toute la
gaule joue sur des consoles haute
définition tout non dans un petit coin
reculé et si c'est un joueur qui résiste
encore et toujours à l'envahisseur
si je vous demande de me citer un
célèbre français connus à l'étranger qui
se promène partout dans le pays avec une
bourde qui le rend surpuissant vous me
dites forcément servian vous me dites
forcément astérix le gaulois la bande
dessinée a été adapté en tout ce qui est
possible kinder pinch de société
peluches fine pot de moutarde dessins
animés et bien évidemment en jeu vidéo
depuis les premières amstrad il existait
déjà des adaptation d'astérix astérix et
le chaudron en 1986 astérix the secrète
mission sur master system
astérix sur nes astérix et obélix sur
super nintendo sur l'a13 idée fixe sur
gameboy aussi 2,8 et encore l'année
dernière ils sortent et astérix aux jeux
olympiques sur xbox 360
c'est dire si la licence continuent à
être utilisés bon à titre personnel mon
jeu préféré restera quand même
l'adaptation arcade sorti en 1991 dans
laquelle j'ai dû engloutir des milliers
de francs mais comme à l'époque il
fallait vendre sa maison pour pouvoir
acheter une neo geo et y jouer chez soi
mais on se contentait de vieille mère de
pourris comme par exemple astérix the
great rescue réservés exclusivement pour
faire souffrir les joueurs de sega j'ai
vraiment pas envie d'y jouer mais
vraiment pas mais le problème c'est que
si je le fais pas il va y avoir encore
des gens qui vont se faire piéger qui
vont jouer à ce jeu seigneur cette
musique la megadrive a toujours eu des
musiques de chiasse mais là ils ont fait
fort quand même
[Musique]
sérieusement est-ce que c'est une
musique vous rappelle astérix je veux
dire la musique d' astérix ça peut être
ça
où ça astellas
ça va cogner
ou même ça
[Musique]
mais pas ce à quoi et encore c'est
vraiment pas la pire parce que j'y ai
joué à ce jeu et croyez moi c'est de la
diarrhée sont morts si on cherchait un
meilleur moyen d'éviter aux jeunes de
passer trop de temps devant leur écran
on l'a trouvé
parce que si vous ne voulez pas que
votre cervelle explosé recouvrir les
murs de votre appartement
croyez moi vous êtes obligé de
régulièrement faire une pause pour allez
vous prendre une plaie flacon d'aspirine
[Musique]
astérix and the great place q oui nous
the great rescue rue le dire ne suis pas
le tracé d'une bande dessinée
contrairement à d'autres jeux il s'agit
en fait d'une suite totalement
incohérente de niveau n'ayant aucun
rapport de près ou de loin avec la bd
vous pouvez au choix jouer astérix et
obélix en fait vous allez vite vous
apercevoir qui vaut mieux le jouer
exclusivement qu'astérix rien ne
différencie les deux personnages mis à
part que le gros culot bellick oblige à
ramper à des endroits où * d'avancé
floby écran monsieur thapa organe a
vraiment passé un premier niveau je me
dis ouais ok c'est pas mal c'est simple
ça dérange le thème bassin vauban
physiquement moi c'est un peu moche mais
l'univers a l'air relativement respecter
un peu jarlot robin vous savez où dans
l'arbre là comme dans le premier * donc
j'enchaîne avec le deuxième niveau qui
ressemble vaguement un port dans
l'espace de tête je crois mais quoi de
le vide intersidéral derrière je sais
pas je ramasse les grenades à gauche je
bute les crabes
[Musique]
non mais attends sérieux je peux pas
passer ce mur je ne peux pas passer ce
mur y'a rien à faire j'ai tout essayé
le rocket jump à la creg le rebond sur
le poisson façon sonic le passage secret
dans l'eau y'a rien qui marche
non mais [ __ ] de merde quoi le premier
niveau se fait la main dans le slip en
30 secondes et là vous avez la console
allumée depuis moins de 3 minutes et
vous êtes déjà bloqué c'est comme c'est
comme imaginer vous jouer à mario et
donc où vous vous retrouvez autre bout
de trois minutes de jeu bloqué devant un
mur immense sur lequel vous pouvez pas
passer et j'ai encore aujourd'hui ça va
avec internet entre deux sites pornos tu
finis bien par trouver une astuce
mais à l'époque c'était baiser y avait
rien ton jeu tu leur mets terrasse en
bois tissus brillé en achetant des
magazines de trouver la bonne astuce et
en parlant de coop vu que je ne compte
pas m'arrêter là
non allons-y
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et là je dois vraiment vous parler de la
limite de temps parce que croyez moi ce
timer va devenir votre pire ennemi dans
ce jeu vous n'avez pas le droit à
l'erreur vous n'avez pas une seconde à
faire nous vous n'avez même pas une
seconde pour vous remettre les baloches
en place
quand vous lancez un niveau fermé la
porte à clé et éteignez le portable et
changer le message de votre répondeur en
bonjour je ne suis pas disponible allez
vous faire mettre après le mini sonore
parce que je vous le jure ce [ __ ] de
timer est calculé à la seconde près à
les 10 secondes
c'est presque fini plus de soa les sept
secondes je vais te faire ça va le faire
aller end dernier sur les arsenaux
[ __ ] de portage
les décors aussi entre le minable et
l'épileptique je sais qu'on peut pas
juger la qualité des graphismes sur un
jeu de cet âge là mais ils auraient
quand même pu travailler davantage
l'aspect bande dessinée tintin au tibet
même si on n'aime pas le jeu était bien
mieux de ce côté là je vais vous montrer
un niveau de jeu qui va vous faire
comprendre la notion de décors
épileptiques
[Musique]
mais sérieusement comment voulez-vous me
concentrer sur le jeu avec ces espèces
de 2 peer au graff gens qui tombent du
ciel
je veux rien regarder ça je viens de me
faire frapper par un [ __ ] de l'oiseau
qui passait entre l'interface un flocon
de mer de 2 10 m de large et
l'espacement référe sidéral de
l'arrière-plan et puis tiens puisqu'on
aime les spires au graff et moi aussi je
vais rajouter quelques couleurs et
quelques éléments sur mon test après
tout ces jolies dents à et puis si vous
vous sentez partir ne vous inquiétez pas
c'est juste que vous êtes en train de
faire une attaque cérébrale comme moi
car j'ai testé ce jeu
et puis maire mais où soudain épisode
d'astérix où il se bat contre les
bonhommes de neige géants vous souvenez
d'un épisode où ils sont dans un monde
de lego géant
et puis ça sérieux astérix qui marche
des saucisses de francfort géant qui
flottent dans le ciel
non mais bon sang quand les développeurs
nous ont fondu ce concept qu'ils étaient
en train de sniffer du liquide vaisselle
ou quoi
[Musique]
il est pas frais ce jeu bien venir ici
qui n'est pas frais
[Musique]
à la fin des séries de ce niveau
régulièrement vous avez un boss qu'il
faudra vaincre pour accéder au niveau
suivant hélas les boss vont réellement
vous posez un horrible problème
encore un que ce soit pour les boss pour
les simples et demi il est impossible de
tuer quelqu'un qui marche dans le même
sens que vous car la portée de beaucoup
est moins longue que ce qui s'appelle la
xbox de vos adversaires
en gros vous allez prendre les dégâts
avant que votre coup de touche sa cible
de manière pratique ça veut dire que
vous êtes obligés d'attendre que les
ennemis viennent vers vous pour les
taper et donc de perdre de précieuses
secondes qui vont forcément vous manqués
à la fin du niveau
c'est vraiment magnifique
[Musique]
le dernier niveau s'appelle rom et là je
ne vais rien dire je vais juste vous
laisse deviner comment passer ça vous
voyez j'ai trois grenades le mur devant
moi ne se décrit pas et la plateforme
est trop loin pour sauter dessus
j'ai 25 secondes largement assez pour
provoquer un suicide oddity soit dit en
passant avec la musique
une idée non rien du tout à l'aise
pithiviers eh bien regardez il faut
casser le mur de gauche qui contient une
potion de nuages pour faire une
plateforme ai sauté dessus
vous voyez dans un bon jeu il y aurait
une indication que le mur est
destructible comme dans zelda par
exemple y aurait une fissure mais là est
ce que quelqu'un a sérieusement eu une
idée sur ce qu'il fallait faire et même
en connaissant la solution c'est
totalement aléatoire si vous ne touchez
pas les 3000 pixels avec vous prenez
vous n'avez plus qu'à attendre la fin du
timer pour recommencer
c'est pour ça je déteste cette catégorie
de jeu le seul moyen d'avancer c'est de
mémoriser chaque élément chaque
plateforme shag romain chaque truc et de
recommencer 200 fois jusqu'à ce que ça
finisse par passer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est là
ça va cogner
astérix